um Jonica 3 what an insane movie this is
and I mean that is the highest
compliment it is it is like an
exclamation point of a movie and I'm
wondering what that with the sugar glass
budget was on this movie
we broke a lot of glass you did a lot of
this is mostly tempered Oh
I mean anything but really really what I
want to talk about which I'm sure
everyone wants to talk about is the dogs
I really love that this movie is kind of
like the Revenge of the dolls if you yes
everyone's ago is the action movie with
the dog dies this is one where the dogs
are this like the dog to revenge I'm
wondering if that was something you
thought of before the movie how did the
dogs come into play when you were sort
of figuring out the story of jauntily um
no again I have a action notebook like
this thick of all the ideas that
happened one I've been waiting for
literally since the end of the first
film was we're gonna use dogs again
we're gonna do dog I've had this idea to
use them tactically for years it just
didn't fit into the overall vibe of what
we're doing for John wick - so when I
came up to three you know originally
there's just have John with the dogs
most like what would be even better okay
we're gonna have you know this great
female cast member with two - Shepherds
that are gonna take care of it and we'll
be like this mother-daughter
relationship and the sacrifice she gave
them the dogs become a kind of an avatar
for that and I think I saw something
that you were involved with the training
of the dogs themselves you sort of we're
doing the action stuff that the stunt
training the gun training but you're
also involved with fed training of the
dogs themselves yeah that training was
very much a part of my training day I
would go and spend two or three hours
with the dogs and work with the
trainer's and you know really become
like a like a dog trainer to the dogs
and they listened to me we had a great
we developed a really good relationship
the way we shoot in the wider shots
mm-hmm at most homes you'd see a tighter
shot the trainer would be just off
camera you know coping coaxing the dog
to do whatever performance we needed you
know obviously we shoot very wide with
very few edits so we couldn't have a lot
of trainer interactive so it had to be
an on-camera interactive so Holly just
literally became the trainer of a dog
the dogs actually became Sophie
anything I could help but notice that
that in the massive dog scene where the
dogs were just flying in and they were
attacking people and stuff like that a
lot of the time the places on the people
they were attacking was the the groin
area I'm wondering if there was the
practical reason for that or that was
just like a yeah yes
we always say like when you see the John
Wood gun foo okay what is a tactically
correct way to to do what John does and
the DoubleTap the Mozambique technique
to the chest one of the head becomes
very practically so we just went back to
the drawing board okay
you know we went to all our animal
trainers went okay what's the number one
you know you see in movies used to be
the forum and that was because the the
trainer the stunt person was protecting
themselves but in reality they're
trained to go for so we're like okay
well if John wick is about head shots at
ox it'll be about groin bites and about
figuring out how to make it as safe as
we can for not just the stunt performer
so he doesn't actually get bit but how
do we protect the dog we don't wanna
hurt the dog's neck we don't make the
dog's teeth matter so we have to come up
with ways to do that and things for them
to actually bite and latch on to without
injuring either side of it a lot of
trust
okay I'm wondering it in your mind if
you see you mentioned you have the
notebook of of things to do I'm gonna if
you mind if you ever see a limit to it
John wick set-piece if there's anything
that that you think is outside the realm
of possible you know I think that's a
great thing that can of I was I've
always talked about is like we you know
it's did John what universe hasn't been
overly defined and so we can pretty much
as far as our imagination goes I think
an audience interest goes I think we can
take it as far as we want to go you know
there's always like you know we try just
because of the the etiquette we have
with the characters you know we limit
our profanity we limit our nudity we
limit gore in general just to push you
more towards the choreography and the
the aesthetically pleasing us of the
action not just the violence